it's not perfect
and i think that consumers
should
shift expectations a little bit omicron
the covet 19 pandemic supply chain
issues and inflation groceries are more
expensive these days but are they really
in short supply supply chain
is not functional functioning all that
well for a variety of reasons
as that trucker convoy moves east a
rolling protest against requirements
that truckers crossing the border be
vaccinated politicians like alberta's
jason kenny are tweeting photos of empty
shelves claiming that there are signs of
a food crisis and the former federal
opposition leader andrew scheer tweeted
that the mandate is threatening
everyone's ability to get groceries i'm
just concerned about how some people may
weaponize pictures with empty shells
in them and and that's really a
dangerous thing to do especially right
now the last thing we need
our consumers
panic buying it would just put even more
pressure on the system global news went
to four downtown toronto supermarkets to
look for shortages in every store owned
by the largest food chains loblaw sobeys
and metro shelves were full and being
restocked all the time
where some brand names had run out
competitor items were still on the shelf
i suspect that importers will remain
active and will make sure that shells
remain stocked as much as possible i
mean empty shells are bad for business
pictures of some empty shelves don't
tell the whole story charlibaugh says
there have been hit and miss inventory
issues for months now despite slowdowns
high demands and higher prices he says
consumers won't face shortages they'll
do everything they can to stock up those
shelves shawn o'shea global news